avec nous aussi mot nouvelle semaine
nouvelle la lutte contre l'alcoolisme au
volant c'est l'aspect le plus
spectaculaire des choses mais est ce que
vous avez vraiment tous les moyens pour
vous en prendre aux roues vraies racines
de l'alcoolisme en france tous les
moyens ce serait difficile à dire mais
je crois qu'il faut toujours commencer
une campagne et que l'alcoolisme au
volant est certainement un des aspects
qui sera le mieux compris par les
français parce qu'ils voient les
conséquences de façon très frappante
elles ont été soulignés ici par monsieur
gauche voudrait d'ailleurs insisté sur
les conditions dans lesquelles monsieur
hugo a fait ces travaux qui sont
absolument scientifiques et qu'ils ont
vraiment il a pris un ensemble
d'accidents dans une somme donniez et
quelques fois en 10 euros les
statistiques c'est retient on ne prend
pas soin des plaies sont impressionnants
sont impressionnantes et tout à fait
tout à fait exact et je pense que pour
que healy et d'une campagne qui
réussissent dans un pays il faut que les
gens comprennent et adhère aller contre
le sentiment le sentiment profond d'une
opinion je crois que c'est la source
d'un succès et dans ce domaine les
accidents de voiture du halal de
l'alcoolisme
c'était sans doute sûrement un les
aspects qui sera mieux compris mais bien
sûr ce n'est pas suffisant il ya
beaucoup d'autres choses à free pour les
causes par exemple on va vous dire que
rien n'est fait pour vraiment un freiner
la production d'un kwh en france on va
freiner la production froid surtout
qu'il faut donner le sentiment aux
gentils son producteur que ce n'est pas
eux qu'on leur en veut et qu'il faut
leur donner d'autres possibilités
économiques d'existence et d'ailleurs ce
n'est pas non plus lutter comme l'a
souligné monsieur gaulle lui même ce
n'est pas d'hier ne buvait plus de 20 du
tout ne pouvait plus d'alcool c'est à
dire simplement buvez en moins et ne se
trouvait pas dans une situation où
justement soit vous pouvez avoir une
action que soi-même vous dépasser ce que
votre santé peut supporter ça ne veut
donc pas du tout dire qu'on veut
arracher toutes les vignes bien sûr et
sans doute peut-être pour certaines
éventuellement effectivement sur le plan
économique prévoir des reconversions
encourager aussi peut-être dans les
cafés d'autres boissons pas de sa
populaire estimant même la ministre vous
avez présenté hier en conseil des
ministres
un projet d'augmentation des datations
familiale et vous avez dit que sur un an
ça faisait 10 7 % de majoration à tous
ses biens est-ce que c'est suffisant
pour relancer une véritable politique
familiale pour relancer la démographie
bras vous d'abord dire que c'est même
pour certaines familles se sera même
dans l'année plus que 17 % puisque
l'augmentation qui a été annoncée hier
est de 6 pour 25% sur l'ensemble sur les
prestations familiales en général mais
que les allocations familiales
elles-mêmes seront augmentées pour
certaines familles en supplément
familial en plus et en plus le convoi
royal mais déjà certains les allocations
familiales concert d'une famille plus
que comptent les ventes légales
donc ce sera pour beaucoup de familles
beaucoup plus que que les 17% les 17%
dans l'année alors bien sûr une
politique familiale sont intègres
d'autres choses que les prestations
familiales il n'y a pas que l'aspect
financier il ya les questions de
logement
il ya les problèmes d'éducation il ya
toute l'organisation de vie des jeunes
et nous essayons sur eux
tous ces plans d'apporter des solutions
mais des gens que la famille par exemple
qu'avec le complément familial 400 à 500
mille familles vont se trouver avec 340
francs de plus par mois net puisque si
si elle ne touche à rien ça fera plus de
4000 francs dans l'année plus de 4000
fois dans l'année pour certaines
familles ça représente la treizième mois
je crois font pas les choses avec des
chars le troisième thème maintenant la
généralisation la cible et sociales
alors ce n'est pas une unification mais
une multiplication de petits régimes
particuliers s'est pas déjà pas si
simple le risque était une bonne chose
que d'accumuler petit régime
par exemple le clergé qui a régi ma part
oui alors devant ce n'est pas une
multiplication de petits régimes
particuliers puisque pour la plupart des
personnes qui vont bénéficier de la
généralisation qui jusqu'à maintenant
donc n'avait rien c'est en fait le
rattachement à un régime existant et en
deux clans sauf en ce qui concerne
l'assurance vieillesse pour le clergé
pour les autres personnes nous ne
faisons que les rattacher à un régime
qui existent soit le régime général soit
le régime les travailleurs indépendants
dont il n'y a pas de création autonome
de nouveau régime mais je voudrais
souligner que
c'est bien sûr un peu complexe simple
alors que si on disait tous les français
payent la même chose pour avoir les
mêmes droits ça serait plus simple mais
les français sont très attachés à avoir
des régimes spécifiques et d'ailleurs en
1975 le parlement avait bien dit que
même en généralisant il ne souhaitait
pas et même il ne voulait pas qu'on
touche aux régimes existants par exemple
je crois que les paysans sont très
attachés à leur région autonome si on
voulait tout d'un coup supprimer le
régime des mines le régime de la sncf le
régime des fonctionnaires loi qui lui
aurait absolument il y aura un tollé
alors chef c'est un peu un mythe cette
unité en tout cas pour l'instant
et nous n'avons pas beaucoup compliqué
puisque le un million deux cent mille
personnes qui vont bénéficier la
généralisation vont entrer dans ces
systèmes qui existent avec des
cotisations semblable est également des
prestations semblables
ce modèle pour terminer un doigt de
politique je mets que vous regardiez
avec moins ce petit reportage qu'a fait
jean claude rigaud qui nous a suivis à
lyon et ou qui prouvait que vous essayer
de dialoguer avec les femmes apparemment
d'après le téléphone ce reportage ne
démarrera pas donc nous n'entendons pas
votre le dialogue mais est-ce que vous
êtes satisfait de ce dialogue avec un
maillot marin ce dans d'autres endroits
lille aussi très bon je trouve ce genre
de réunions très très intéressant parce
qu elles sont très rapides très vive et
qui a un vrai dialogue comme vous venez
de le dire puisque au cours de ces
réunions où j'étais que vous avez fait
état on a présenté le film qui avait qui
reprend le dialogue le président de la
république avait eu avec un certain
nombre de femmes est peu ça devient le
thème d'une discussion sans que je fasse
une espèce d'exposer préliminaire qui
est toujours un peu pour les auditeurs
un peu ennuyeux ce genre d'exposer ex
cathedra et elle me pose absolument
toutes les questions je ne sais pas si
c'est les réponses et intéresse mais en
tout cas moi je peux dire que de voir
quelles sont les préoccupations des
femmes
je trouve ça passionnant et selon les
régions ce qui est très curieux sont les
réunions
le climat est très différent alors on se
demande si c'est parce que on a touché
un public différent si c'est parce qu'en
france yens spécificités des régions
mais on retrouve tout de même certains
thèmes communs qui montre que les femmes
ont des problèmes précis
qu'elle souhaite pour le rapport des
solutions et qu'elles sont aussi très
très positive c'était très concrète et
qu'elle se rende compte qu'on ne peut
pas tout faire je crois que là c'est un
aspect très important terrien ses taux
quand on explique les femmes sont des
gens responsables elles comprennent très
bien qu'on ne peut pas tout faire qu'il
faut faire des choix et on les amène à
comprendre pourquoi on fait certains
jours nous sommes obligés de nous
quitter si bonne nouvelle car il avait
un petit peu de retard
j'ai parlé très rapidement de la météo
pour vous dire qu'il gagne